>>> MORE BREAKING NEWS TO REPORT
THIS FRIDAY NIGHT.
THIS TIME ON THE HEALTH OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO RECEIVED A
PHYSICAL EXAM TODAY.
HIS FIRST SINCE TAKING OFFICE AS
THE OL OL OLDEST FIRST-TERM
PRESIDENT IN MYSTERY.
WANT TO TALK WITH SANJAY GUPTA
WHO IS ALSO NAUR OF THE
FASCINATING NEW BOOK, WORLD WAR
C LESSONS FROM THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC AND HOW TO PREPARE FOR
THE NEXT ONE.
SO, SANJAY, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THE RESULTS OF THIS
PHYSICAL?
>> WELL, WE HAD SOME IDEA OF
SOME OF THE PRESIDENT'S PAST
MEDICAL HISTORY.
WE ALSO KNOW HE IS THE OLDEST
FIRST-TERM PRESIDENT.
SO PUTTING THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER, THERE WERE SPECIFIC
THINGS THAT I THINK THEY WERE
SORT OF TARGETING.
WE KNOW THAT HE HAS THIS HISTORY
OF REFLUX, FOR EXAMPLE.
WE KNOW HE HAS A HISTORY OF
ATRIAL FIBRILLATION.
THEY WERE FOCUSED ON THE FACT
THAT HIS -- HIS GAIT -- HIS
WALKING, ANDERSON, SEEMS TO HAVE
CHANGED A BIT.
THEY DESCRIBE IT AS BEING LESS
FLUID, STIFFER GAIT.
WE ALSO KNOW HE TAKES THIS
MEDICATION FOR HIS CHOLESTEROL
AND HE HAD A COLONOSCOPY.
SO THOSE WERE SORT OF THE MAJOR
THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF THAT AND
THERE -- THERE WERE A FEW
FINDINGS.
HIS REFLUX IS STILL PERSISTENT
WHICH IS WHY THEY THINK HE'S
BEEN COUGHING A LOT.
YOU MAY HEAR HIM CLEARING HIS
THROAT A LOT DURING SPEECHES.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE CAUSE OF
THAT.
AS FAR AS HIS GAIT BEING
CHANGED, THEY THINK HE DEVELOPED
SOME ARTHRITIS IN HIS LOWER
BACK.
HE HAS A HISTORY OF HAVING HIS
BRAIN SURGERY -- HAVING
ANEURYSMS OPERATED BACK IN THE
LATE '80s.
THAT APPEARS TO HAVE NOT
CHANGED.
AND -- AND THEN, AGAIN THIS
CO
COLON OCHKPY FOR WHICH HE WAS
SEDATED AND ALSO HAD AN
ENDOSCOPY AS WELL.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF FOCUS ON HIS COGNITIVE
ABILITIES.
QUESTIONS RAISED BY -- BY
OPPONENTS AND OTHERS IN 2018 THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HAD A TEST THAT
MEASURED MEANT ACUITY.
WAS THAT PART OF TODAY'S TEST?
>> DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT.
I READ PRETTY CAREFULLY THROUGH
THE DOCTOR REPORT AND THEY
MENTION NEUROLOGICAL EXAM BUT
MORE IN TERMS OF TESTING MOTOR
STRENGTH AND SENSATION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD SOMETHING
KNOWN AS THE MONTREAL COGNITIVE
ASSESSMENT.
IT IS SORT OF A SCREENING TEST
FOR -- FOR DEMENTIA AND, UM, YOU
KNOW, THERE WAS NO MENTION OF
THAT SORT OF THING HERE.
IT IS A CONSTANT POINT OF
CONSTITUTION, I CAN TELL YOU,
WITHIN THE GERIATRICS COMMUNITY.
I WROTE THIS BOOK LAST YEAR
ABOUT BRAIN HEALTH.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT KEPT
COMING UP WAS SHOULD SORT OF
THESE TYPES OF SCREENING TESTS,
COGNITIVE SCREENING TESTS, BE
MORE COMMONLY DONE AND THERE IS
MANY IN THIS COMMUNITY WHO
BELIEVE STARTING AT AGE 65,
THERE SHOULD BE SOME SORT OF
SCREENING THAT'S DONE.
DR. RONALD PETERSON WHO RUNS THE
ALZHEIMER'S CLINIC AT MAYO HAS
BEEN SOMETHING WHO HAS TALKED
ABOUT THAT.
BUT AS FAR AS WE KNOW FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WE DIDN'T SEE
ANY KIND OF TEST LIKE THAT
PERFORMED.
>> WE SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT THE
PRESIDENT'S PHYSICAL MADE
HISTORY TODAY.
HE TEMPORARILY TURNED OVER
PRESIDENTIAL AUTHORITY TO VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS WHICH IS THE
FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN HISTORY
THAT A WOMAN HAD THE POWER OF
THE PRESIDENT SO INTERESTING DAY
IN HISTORY.
I WANT TO TURN TO THE FIGHT
AGAINST COVID, THOUGH.
TODAY, CDC AND FDA ENDORSED
BOOSTER VACCINES FOR ALL
AMERICANS 18 YEARS AND OLDER.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL US ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE IN THIS -- IN THIS
FIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT TELLS US A
BIT ABOUT WHAT THE VACCINES ARE
DOING.
AND THEY SEEM TO HAVE -- BE VERY
PROTECTIVE STILL BUT WANING A
BIT IN TERMS OF THAT
PROTECTIVENESS.
IT COULD BE BECAUSE OF TIME,
LIKE HOW MUCH TIME HAS PASSED
BETWEEN SINCE PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN
THEIR SHOTS.
IT COULD JUST BE BECAUSE OF THIS
DELTA VARIANT BUT AS WE GO INTO
THE WINTER AND COOLER AND DRIER
MONTHS, PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE -- THE CONTAGIOUSNESS
OF THIS VIRUS GROWING EVEN AND
MIGHT THAT HAVE A GREATER
IMPACT?
WHAT IS INTERESTING, ANDERSON,
IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE
THINGS STAND NOW, MOST ADULTS
WERE ALREADY ELIGIBLE FOR
BOOSTERS EITHER BECAUSE OF AGE
OR BECAUSE OF
PRE-EXISTING-HEALTH CONDITIONS.
CLOSE TO 90% OF ADULTS WERE
ALREADY ELIGIBLE BUT IT WAS
CONFUSING.
LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW THEY
WERE ELIGIBLE.
TODAY, BASICALLY SAID EVERYBODY
WHO IS AN ADULT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
THE BOOSTER.
THEY TOOK IT A STEP FURTHER EVEN
AND SAID IF YOU ARE OVER THE AGE
OF 50, YOU SHOULD GET A BOOSTER.
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT -- THAT'S
SORT OF WHERE WE ARE.
BUT I WANT TO -- I WANT TO SHOW
YOU WHAT I THINK ARE INTERESTING
GRAPHS THAT TELL THE STORY.
IN THE UNITED STATES, IF YOU
LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO GET
HOSPITALIZED FOR COVID, THEY ARE
STILL THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE -- THAT'S THE RED LINE --
THEY ARE UNVACCINATED.
THE GREEN LINE, AT THE BOTTOM,
UP UNTIL THE END OF SEPTEMBER,
RELATIVELY FLAT BUT IT STARTED
TO TICK UP.
IF YOU LOOK AT ISRAELI DATA SORT
OF OVER THE FALL GOING UP TO
NOVEMBER 1st, IT REALLY I THINK
IMPORTANT PICTURE EMERGED HERE.
SO UNVACCINATED ON THE LEFT.
THEY ARE STILL THE EVACUATE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO END UP
WITH SEVERE COVID.
BUT THERE WAS PEOPLE WHO HAD